I'm happy to welcome Markus Rabe
from UC Berkeley here today to
give us a talk about
program synthesis, and
quantify elimination, and
QBF, and things like that.
So Markus has been there for
a couple of years, and
this is a Physicist in Saarland
University with on Hyper LTL.
So, I'm happy to have you here,
and so,
not to take away more time,
please.
>> Thanks for the introduction.
Yeah, my background is more in
informational security, for
methods temporal logics,
and so on.
But recently I've been more
shifting over to the synthesis
aspect of formal methods,
mostly, and
my overall goal is to apply
this back into security,
where I think it would
have a tremendous use.
So while earlier,
or previously, or
some years back we still thought
that critical programming errors
result in the some things
like that, or this.
Today it looks more like that,
and these are like scams
that lock your computer and
you can only unlock them for
money, or like that where
someone hacks into your car and
you end up crashing your car.
So, I think, there is a shift in
the attention from the safety
aspects to the security aspects,
and that is, I guess, mostly
driven by the economic impact,
which is estimated in
the many billions.
These are obviously people
who are profiting from
a high estimate here,
but I think it's
fair to say there is a really
big economic push towards it.
I think today might even
be the tipping point for
like people taking security
more serious, because today,
I think, it is the first CEO
who had to step down because of
a big data breach.
So that may actually
change something.
>> He's not the first one.
>> And he's not the last one.
>> He's not the first one,
really?
>> I don't think so.
At least with a major company,
as far as I recall,
maybe there are more.
[LAUGH]
>> I think he's the number
one reason why?
I've heard that quote.
>> Okay, [LAUGH] I mean they're
definitely concerned about
it now, yeah [LAUGH].
>> Point, maybe the tipping
point is happening even more.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Unless we hear whether this
Springfield stuff is right.
I've heard this
quote several times.
>> Okay, okay, cool.
>> Go ahead.
>> So all the while,
we actually know how to
design secure systems.
There have been several major
attempts at formally verifying
systems with a very high
standard of certainty.
The seL4 Microkernel was maybe
the first real big example
showing it, but there are major
other efforts in this area.
However, they still
didn't reach practical,
or the normal
software development,
because it's still
pretty expensive, and
I think that for
the cost reason, and for others,
I think that program synthesis
will have a major impact,
and I think that will be mostly
in three different ways.
First of all, while the standard
view of program synthesis is
that we can synthesize
performed code, or
low-level code,
from high levels of abstraction,
and that would reduce the
complexity in software designs.
It could help too, and
in particularly it could reduce
the amount of low-level coding
that's really error prone.
Now that is the sort of standard
view of problem synthesis, but
I think there are different ways
how problem synthesis could
be really used.
It could all synthesize, and
prove objects for the improvers,
which is I think would help to
directly lower the cost of these
major verification efforts,
and we could also use that
in an automated program analysis
in all it's variants, and
synthesize things like
invariance, ranking functions,
and so on.
And by that at least
find in existing code,
which is also very
helpful too of course.
Now I see that, I considered
the problem synthesis isn't
a very general fashion here.
I think that it typically has
this pattern where we ask well,
does it exist some program or
some syntactic object or
some class of things
that we can describe.
There's that for all inputs.
Some specification halt.
Typically we can compile these
synthesis problems into such
a format, and that could be also
existed proof, such that, for
all possible sums of
the variables it is true,
something like that
would kind of represent
the pure improving aspect of it,
maybe.
But, I think, if we manage
to solve this problems,
in a fairly general and fast
way, this could help in many
different ways, and would really
help for software security.
So, however, of course, I think
everyone is aware of that,
program synthesis is really
not scalable so far.
If we are really lucky,
it scales to five to ten lines
of code, and, but for that we've
probably already have to
restrict the program very much.
So this is really the biggest
issue of that approach yet.
So the approach that I want
to take is to identify
the fundamental scalability
issues behind this, and for
that I want to reduce the
problem to its simplest form.
To a very pure form where we can
actually analyze the problems,
and that is I believe,
it's synthesis problem is
quantified boolean formulas.
We will even further restrict
it to just quantified boolean
formula with one quantified
destination just to look
at the core of the problem, and
that we'll study today, and for
that I will just suggest
a new algorithm, and
then we'll evaluate it, and for
that we started out with some
synthesis benchmarks that
we're essentially, well,
synthesizing some
proof objects and
then we also took some
benchmarks from the sketch.
Benchmarks really like
that is Amanda's.
Amanda helped us in generating,
basically,
Boolean encodings off this
problem synthesis benchmarks.
While a reason why
we picked that is,
well obviously these
were available.
We didn't have to
do it ourselves,
which is I think a good
thing for benchmarking,
because that means
you cannot cheat.
We have the files first before
we developed the algorithm.
Then all these three families
included some unsolved problems,
and so it was possible to
measure some progress towards
synthesis there, because I
don't believe that we can
suddenly scale to hundreds
of lines of code, so
we didn't wanna set a goal
that was too large.
Now just to be a bit
more concrete,
the ranking function problem
has problems like that.
We are given
the boolean problem,
over some say variables, and
we basically just ask whether
it's just a constant C,
such that for all states x and x
prime if they are successes, so
if x prime is the successor of
x, then the multiplication of
the constant with a must
be smaller than the, well,
the product of the content
with the previous date.
So, a very simple encoding.
That was done by Cook and
some others,
and they included programs
mostly taken from Windows device
drivers, of course they
are reduced ones, but
they had to be realistic bits.
So they're encodings of 16 bit,
32 bit and 64 bit, and
they have small
snippets like that.
I think this is one of
the smallest snippets.
It basically asks whether,
will it be given two variables.
We only know about them that
they are equal on their last
five bits, apparently,
for whatever reason, or
they're not equal on the last
five bits, sorry, and
then we are counting one up,
and sorry, apparently
someone had a small counter in
the last five bits of code and
tried to have a loop over these.
Okay, it turns out this is
a non-terminating program.
Because if index is
different to have on the,
Bits that it doesn't compare
it with, then we store that in
the integer i and here in this
comparison, it will always fail.
Because we can always count
up the last five bits but
it will never do anything.
So and as a human, you can spot
that and it's not that hard,
but it's not so easy if you just
see a sea of classes and bits.
And this is a problem that can
be encoded apparently in some
3000 classes with
a 32 bit semantics.
It has some 128 variable, so
don't you wanna
enumerate things.
And in the end, it turns out
we can solve these things, but
very quickly within,
say 100 milliseconds.
Okay, all right.
>> So, [INAUDIBLE]
>> Yeah, sure.
>> I think most non-ranking
function exists for opposite.
>> So they exist,
non ranking, yeah.
And to prove the absence
is nontrivial,
it is of course not
a particularly hard for humans,
but we want to automize these
things and this kind of,
I just want to justify that this
is a reasonable benchmark for synthesis-
>> Both non-ranking function
exists means it
does not terminate?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah, exactly and
the other problems we considered
were then, things like function
summaries of Boolean programs
and program sketches.
And these were sometimes
substantially larger, so
the synthesis problems we
considered were typically like
50,000 clauses, some at 100,000,
200,000 clauses.
But, I mean, this is not
particularly impressive for
SMT solver or for
SaaS solvers, but
we are trying to solve a harder
problem here, so that's kind of,
I think, it's a reasonable
synthesis benchmarks.
If we can do that,
we did some progress.
Okay, this talk, I'll basically
go through this schedule here.
And first of all, take a look
at the existing synthesis
algorithms on
the program level and
try to identify what
their problems are.
And at least one problem,
I mean, I'm not suggesting
that I'm solving everything.
And then we'll do the step
to QBFN codings and
we'll take a look at that and
see what the problems are with
QBFN algorithms are and then
we'll go into the algorithm.
We'll go through
the emulation and
then we have two parts that
are kind of more an outlook.
There's one theoretical
work on how to lift this to
reasoning about functions and
some quantitative works
that also we need.
I hope, we actually make it
through the last part, as well,
will depend a bit on the timing.
All right, CEGIS, this is a very
general algorithmic scheme to
solve synthesis queries.
And basically, we want to just
have a version for-looper,
pick a candidate program,
wanna check whether it's the one
we're looking for and if not,
then we exclude some programs
from the next query,
and iterate.
Well, we can see that as
a learning framework,
people have been exploring
the theory on that and
anyways, there are two
main flavors of that.
Which is the enumerative
synthesis approach and
the SNT solver approach, maybe,
there's also this ecclesiastic
one that I won't go
into too much today.
And they both come
with their problems,
like, the enumerative
approach is to enumerate
syntactic expressions
from small to large.
And kind of to always evaluate
them against the count examples
you've found so far.
And that is we can enumerate
things really quickly, but
of course, it's clear that once
the programs we're looking for
get too large, then a number of
possibilities just explodes and
we won't get anywhere.
Unless we restrict the grammar
so much that the number of
possibilities is kind of small,
but then we have to sort-of know
what we're looking for so it's
kind of not really a solution
in the long run, I believe.
So the other problem is to use
an SNT solver which does not
necessarily suffer so
much from this explosion, but
it turns out,
in practice, it does.
Like after we add some
subqueries, SNT solvers tend to
have real problems, at least,
on the even codings.
I'm not sure whether they
are much better ones, but so
far in literature, it seems that
often the problem is with SNT
solver was after adding
a number of counterexamples,
things really start to get slow.
And there's one problem that
both of these approaches share,
which is that, for
some examples, you just need
too many count examples.
In particular, for
those where we have to
refute the existence of
an object in a certain grammar.
Let's take a look at this
very simple program sketch,
I sort of think many people have
seen that [INAUDIBLE] has like
promoted that kind
of thing a lot.
This is a program snippet or
small function that just has one
hole in it which is denoted by
these two question marks and
the problem is to find
a constant by which you want to
replace these two
question marks,
such that the program doesn’t
violate the desertion.
Now the dysfunction is,
we supposed to do
something really stupid, really
simple, it's supposed to return
a number that is different
to the input, right?
So we're given some y as
an input and we have to then
the constant, but that is a
constant, it cannot depend on y.
And then they are supposed
to be different,
it is clear that such
a constant cannot exist, right?
For any constant we choose,
you can pick the same input and
it's same way, but
CEGIS engines really have
problems with this example,
they will just enumerate,
enumerate and count examples.
And each count example only
excludes a single constant,
so that is a really awkward
example for CEGIS, right?
Now and the way we're
gonna encode that in QBF,
is that we are, unfortunately,
have to negate it,
this is a little bit of a width
point, this point of the doc,
but I assure you this is
only for technical reasons,
because we want
to work with CNF.
So, if we want to encode
our constraints in CNF,
there must be an external
quantifier side.
I assure you this is one of
the only points where this is
a really technical weird
argument in this one.
So we negate our problem,
instead of asking whether there
exists a program that works for
all inputs, we're gonna ask
the question whether for
all programs,
there exists a count example.
It's just a negation
of the problem and
then it's clear that our
problem from above could be
encoded in QBF like that,
we ask whether for
all access that exists to y
is so that x equals y, holds.
I'm sort of assuming an optimal
encoding of this program and
obviously, when we work with
real encodings of programs,
there will be a lot
more clutter at this,
but it's sort of clear that this
is the core of the problem.
All right, if you find a Skolem
function for that, QBF,
that means we prove
that QBF to be true,
we have refuted
the original problem.
Then for every x, we found the y
that satisfies the equation
which would then
violate the assertion.
All right.
All right, now how do QBF
algorithm solve that?
And for QBF, so far or
at least until recently,
the predominant algorithmic
approach was the CEGAR approach.
Which for
2QBF can be said really simple,
we will just take two
SAT solvers, one for
the universal variables,
one for the extension variables.
And we first asked the one for
the universal variables whether
the existence assignment to x.
And it gives us some assignment,
which [INAUDIBLE] constraints.
And we find then
matching assignment for
y, which is an assignment
that for that particular
x satisfies the formula and then
we exclude all the xs like all
the universal assignments that
For which this y is a solution.
In this particular example we
have on the previous slide,
the equality concerns.
This is exactly one
universal assignment.
First of all, this is basically
the same thing, it's just
formulated the other way around
sort of in negated form.
And for our example on
the previous slide,
it's clear that we just
exclude one assignment and
that leads to enumerating all
assignments, also in SAT.
And it turns out that even
the competitive QBF solvers,
from the last couple years
that are based on this
principle just diverge
in that example.
Practically never come back
if you have to enumerate to
do the 32 assignments.
That [INAUDIBLE] is only
true if you don't consider
preprocessing.
There are preprocessors that can
solve that, but we sort of don't
wanna rely too much on
preprocessing here, as soon as
something like that equation
hits our solvers, they're done.
So it's the problem we
see with CEGIS and for
synthesis tools does exist
in the same way for QBF.
So this is sort of another
justification why it makes sense
to actually study the problem
on this low level,
because we really have to solve
this quantifier problem to make
progress.
Now I want to take a step and
just say let's do something
completely new, let's take
a completely fresh view on this.
And consider, so
assume we are given 2QBF, for
all x that fits on y,
to fall in the phi loops.
And let's consider that as a
relation between assignments off
to x, and assignments to y,
all right?
Any pair of assignment to x and
y either is satisfied
by the phi or not.
And this gives us a relation,
implicitly defined,
not only symbolically defined.
And what we want to have in the
end is a Skolem function which
is nothing but a functional and
complete relation.
So we talked already about
the same kind of object,
we just need some
additional properties.
We need, in the end,
to refute or
to prove such a formula
we need to find
a relation that has these
additional properties.
So let's take this
general relation view and
look at what the CEGAR
algorithm is doing.
So the assignment, the relation
here is basically, well, a set
of errors between assignments
to x and assignments to y.
And now there are two cases
that could make a relation
not complete or
not functional, right?
Either there is an assignment to
x that doesn't have a matching
assignment on the other side.
And this is sort of the
assignment that all the CEGAR
algorithms are looking for.
They kind of browse through
the assignments here and
always try to find something on
the other side that matches it.
And if they find something that
doesn't have a matching partner,
they are done.
They found an example.
At some point, they otherwise
exhaust the space of assignments
as universal and they are done.
And we're gonna now
focus on the other case,
namely the one that the relation
might not be functional.
>> Excuse me a second.
>> Yeah, sure.
>> So to get approve it only has
to be it doesn't have to
be functional, right?
Now a non-functional proof
is overkill, so to speak.
It gives more than one example,
but refutes every program.
But nonetheless, you don't
require to have proofs that this
relation be functional.
It's efficient,
but not necessary.
>> True, we could also prove
it with non-functional.
That's a good a point, yeah.
We coud prove it with
nonfunctionals as well.
And the typical view of how
we want to prove it however,
is that Skolem function.
And the Skolem function
is a functional thing.
>> True, true,
that is also good point.
The point, however, why one have
the functionality is with that
property, we can kind of turn
this problem around and take for
the completeness.
If we have
a functional relation,
we can turn
the problem around and
check for the completeness of
relation with the SAT solver.
And then we can kind of ask what
is an input to that relation
that creates a conflict?
And will help to, yeah,
but would I agree?
Yeah, that we could also try to
not generate Skolem functions
with relations.
>> [INAUDIBLE] efficient
[INAUDIBLE] are are sufficient,
right.
>> But if it were efficient,
[INAUDIBLE] they constrain
the functions.
>> Yeah.
>> So right here the function
constraints the,
yeah, the teacher.
All right, so
the future learner.
>> Yeah, all right, we want to
explore that functionality.
However, and I mean,
it comes really handy that it
should be formulated as Skolem
functions, not via relations.
Okay, now, what we're gonna do
is, to take our relation, and
add new constraints until
it becomes functional.
So one could have collapsed
these pairs, where it's not
clear where did you get like
what the matching partner is.
And on the way,
we will check whether we
cannot violate to this
completeness constraint.
Now, the question of course
is what constraints to add?
And here we're gonna take a CDCL
style approach, we are gonna
add simple things that
are not necessarily correct.
We are gonna propagate and
check whether the mistakes, and
if so, then we learn from that.
We'll actually learn
clauses like in CCL.
Now, I think it's best
understood along this example.
It's CNF, I'm aware that
people are not fluent in CNF
necessarily, but I'm going
to lead you through it, and
it's gonna be really simple.
So we have units of variables,
x1, x2, and four extensials.
Let's for now, zoom in on
the first three classes.
And these three classes all
have a particular property.
There's this is one
extensial variable in there,
the other ones are universals,
so
we can read them as
implications, right?
You can negate the left side and
read them as implications.
Then it's clear that these three
classes describe three sort of
functioned cases or
cases of a function.
And it's say's like if both
universal are true then y has to
be true and
otherwise it has false.
So this is an and.
I'm drawing the circuit
here on the right just for
illustration purposes,
just to work,
what the current state of
the functions we learned.
So here we just learn, hey,
there's one variable, if
this whole problem has a Skolem
function, then this variable,
necessarily, has to be the and
of these two universals.
We can do the same thing with
the second group of variables.
However now, waiting,
now we have these classes where
there are two extensials.
However, for
their extensial y one,
we already know
the Skolem function.
So, it's sort of okay to replace
it by a Skolem function and just
let y2 depend on the outcome
of this Skolem function of y1.
So we can learn here, okay,
this is just the OR of x2, and
the outcome of this Skolem
functional, y1, right?
So this is a propagation
step that happened.
By learning that y1 has a
particular Skolem function, this
enabled us to learn that y2 must
have another Skolem function and
we could only do that after
learning Skolem function for y1.
Because otherwise, you would
have these clauses y1 or
y2 that don't have a particular
direction to them, right?
I'm assuming that I have some
more clauses, we might not
always be that lucky as to to
drive all the Skolem functions
and these two clauses here for
y3, they don't.
I mean, they also have
the property that y1 and y2,
they have Skolem functions, and
there's only y3 in there that
doesn't have a Skolem function.
But these two clauses don't
necessarily determine y3 For all
possible signs, right, and it's
not functional at this point, so
let's just add a clause.
Just decide for something, and
we'll later take a look at
what exactly how these
decisions should look like.
Let's just add a single clause
that says if y1 and y2.
So if these two clauses are
satisfied by y1 and y2, that is,
if they both are true,
then y3 should be true.
All right now this
together defines an and.
That's fine, we just guessed it,
so we marked it blue, so
this depends on the decision.
Now we try to continue
propagating, look at y4,
and it will be finite,
that leads to a conflict.
The conflict is that we find
an assignment for x1 and x2 for
the universal variables,
that propagates through.
So, y1, x1, x2,
enter them here we get y1,
y1 implies y2,
as y1 and y2 imply y3.
And now we have this conflict
that says if y1 is true,
then y4 has to be true, if y3
is true, then y4 has to be true.
And y4 has to be false,
and y4 cannot be true and
false at the same time, so
we have conflict, right?
We have to find this
with a subject, and
that we can, we have to find
this [INAUDIBLE] with a subject,
maybe but that's fine.
And now we can go back,
we do computational analysis
in a new clause, like this.
Now it actually turns out
that now If y1 is false,
then y3 has to be false.
And if y1 is true then y3
has to be false too, so
it basically means y3 is defined
to be constantly false here.
That's fine, we learned that
through the conflict laws,
we can propagate that, and
it turns out this works.
Then we can just complete that
other thing, that's fine.
So what we did is,
now we learned a Skolem function
that has three distinct inputs.
But we only needed one
subject to find one conflict,
so we made some magic happen.
A approach would have taken
at least three cycles,
three iterations.
And in general, there could have
been much more stuff around it
that we'd just derive, and
that wouldn't have taken
any additional set calls.
So really did something
new here, I think,
and I would say that this,
I would explore.
It's the functional dependencies
among the variables that
are there in the CNF to define
the school of functions that
are uniquely there.
And thereby, we avoid the
enumeration of the inputs, so
what I think this-
>> So
do you depend on
a topological source?
>> The topology, or the ordering
among the variables,
is derived on the fly.
There's no predetermined order,
is that the question,
does that answer the question?
So while-
>> What if all lines
appear in all closers?
>> Then we are pretty
much screwed,
usually that doesn't happen.
In particular, for
titan encoded problems,
[INAUDIBLE] we have two or
three variables, or
four or five, sometimes.
So I think the best way to
see this algorithm is that
we lifted the CDCL algorithm
from SAT to the function space.
Instead of propagating values,
we're propagating functions.
Or rather, we are propagating
the property that certain
variables have unique functions,
but so,
This slide also shows how this
should probably be implemented.
And the state of a is
essentially a partial
assignment of the variables.
And mapping from variables
to boolean values, or
to an undefined value.
In a QBF algorithm, we'll have
a partial assignment from
extensial variables,
only the extensials,
to either a Skolem function or
an undefined value.
And a Skolem function will just
be described by a set
of constraints.
We won't have to represent them
in any other way that they,
we just identify certain groups
of constraints that we know
represent functions.
Then decisions will be
essentially, again,
adding constraints, instead
of adding single literal,
and conflicts work
a little bit different.
We can't use unit
propagation only,
we actually need a SAT
call to find conflicts.
Instead of just propagating the
existing partial assignment and
getting a conflicting
example of y and not y.
We have to ask th whether they
exist in the assignment or
input to the functions
we have already,
such that we propagate y and
not y.
So that is kind of a major gap
between these two worlds but
learning will then be remarkably
similar also in clauses.
And what I think is most
important, and this is where I
think people don't believe me
at first when I talk about it,
is we need this notion
of propagation.
So that almost would be
completely useless without unit
propagation, right?
We need this discovery
of new things,
of unique parts of the solution,
and so
that is the thing that I
think is really a novelty.
If one thing of this work
survives a longer time,
then it will be this
propagation of this property
that's certainly, we need to
have unique Skolem functions.
And let's find out
roughly at least,
so to define a unique
Skolem function, we first
need to find what it means that
the clause has a direction.
We call a clause is a unique
consequence, and so
see we're given a quantified
boolean formula.
And a set of variables D that
already has a unique Skolem
function, whatever that means.
So then a clause is set to
have a unique consequence.
Say the unique consequence ln,
the last literal here, I mean,
we can reorder them otherwise.
If this variable is not yet in
D, it's an extensial variable,
but it's not in D.
And all the other literals in
that clause already have either
a Skolem function, or
they are universal.
So in other words, if you
want to express it in natural
language, the clauses
are unique consequence L.
If L is the only extential
variable in it that does not yet
have a Skolem function,
it's sort of like the unit,
The unit clause property,
when all but
one literals are assigned,
we can propagate the last one.
In this case, they are not
necessarily assigned, but
they just need to have
a Skolem function.
And then we know that this
clause has a direction, right?
Okay, where within has
a unique Skolem function,
this property also,
we say, it must hold.
That for all possible
assignments to universals and
all the unique assignments
to the variables in D.
They all have functions,
so they're all determined
in the universal variable.
So for any assignment to
access unique extension to
the variables in D, that is
determined by the clauses,
curly D that already have
defined Skolem functions.
Such that there exists exactly
one value for this variable v,
and if that is the case, then v
has a unique Skolem function.
And its unique value must be
determined only by the clauses
with any consequence, only those
that we have identified to have
some direction.
Then we know that this is an
approximation of what it means
that as a unique
Skolem function.
We only take into account these
unique consequence losses, not
the other ones, and that they
could be even Whole groups of
variables in classes that only
have one unique assignment or
something, but
we don't find that.
So this is an approximation
that only takes into account
the really local situation, but
it's efficient to find unique
scoring functions in many cases.
And furthermore,
this can be checked with
two simple fact checks.
I mean, as expected, we check
with the relations locally,
functional or
whether it's locally conflicted.
This just means these
curly D are the classes
that only contain universal
variables and variables in D.
So these are our scoring
function coefficients,
those that we have
derived already.
And then we ask basically
whether the conjunction of all
the antecedents of the universal
unique consequences and
that can be satisfied.
This means that
the exists a time for
which no unique value for
v is determined.
You got a question?
>> You're saying that one way,
so a clause gives either a lower
bound or an upper bound for
a variable, depending on whether
the variable is positive or
negative?
>> Yeah.
>> So Davis-Putnam will
give you the full upper and
lower bounds, so that this
gives you the range of values
as a function of
other variables.
And then uniqueness is
whether the upper and
lower bound are tight, so
you could subtract the lower
bound with the upper bound.
>> This is a view we'll get
to in a couple of slides and
that's just another way how to-
>> And
that's where you have delay
finding with those function?
>> Yeah, until we find out that
it's actually the case here,
yeah.
And conflict will be the same or
similar.
We just have to ask whether
they are kind of
opposing assignments.
I mean,
we don't go through these exact.
For me, it is sort of clear
that we can formulate
these small subqueries that only
go in the neighborhood here and
they also ask
the global situation.
Now we can approximate these.
No, I think I've taken this
out of the presentation.
But anyways, we can approximate
these two texts by just
dropping the these core
function coefficients.
This gives us then
the purely local picture,
what only happens with
the classes that this particular
variable's involved in.
And then we get two
different approximations.
We get an under-approximation of
what it means that the variable
is functional, and
an over-approximation of what
it means if it's conflicted.
But we can use that to
speed up the algorithm.
Anyway, this is just
a principle of unit.
Let's take an abstract
unit again, and
let's assume we have some group
of variables like before.
x is our universal,
y is our extential.
D is our set of variables for
which we have a unique Skolem
function, so
this is kind of a blue circle.
This kind of includes all these
arrows which D stands for
some clauses, and that uniquely
define the functions for one,
two and three.
Now the unique consequence
are those that kind of leave
that area.
And we might have a class
by three or not by four,
where three is a variable with
a unique Skolem function.
So we see that this class must
be a unique consequence or
must have a unique consequence.
Now this is a class that
actually should involve,
it should be multi-edge.
It should include y1,
y2, and y4.
This is a unique consequence,
of course.
We want to know what you
are already determined.
All right, now exactly where we
will go to this sort of partial
function view, or
under approximation.
Each of these classes with
unique consequence define a case
of this function definition,
right?
This class goes
in this top line.
It says y4 has to be defined
as true if not by one,
and not by two, also.
Then the other two classes
define phases in which
the variable has to be false.
And then we have this
unknown area in between.
It could be more cases
that we don't really know.
And the two checks that we do,
the functionality and
the conflict, and essentially,
to ask whether this question
mark area,
this little area is empty.
If so, then it's functional.
And we can ask whether
there's maybe a conflict
which means that there's u
on the one area overlap.
A decision now will be to assign
this grey area, the middle area,
to either the true area or
the false area.
We could also take more
elaborate decisions,
but it turns out that very
stupid decisions are often fine.
Because if we fail,
we learn new clauses, and
we will get new entries
in this function table.
All right, now let's assume
y4 is functional and
it's not conflicted,
so we can propagate it.
What happens is that, while
we include it in the set D,
the algorithm propagates, the D
gets extended and these are not
unique consequences anymore,
but others will be then.
And then we can maybe
propagate more.
All right, l mean it's pretty
straightforward so far.
Now conflict analysis.
What happens if
something is wrong and
we run into a conflict, we take
some wrong decisions and so on?
Let's go sort of back to
our previous example,
we have our clauses and
variables here.
And we have the conflict for
variable y4,
which was provoked only if we
have this assignment x1 and x2.
Because then this
clause propagates,
this clause propagates,
this clause propagates.
This is nothing else but what's
called an implication graph,
where we have now just
two types of decisions.
We have universal variables,
which are earmarked in black,
and we have these blue
variables, which are essential
decision variables, where we
just added a clause, right?
Because the conflict was
only introduced because we
added our wrong decision, right?
And this wrong decision is
represented by these two blue
arrows and
white three being true.
All right, so what do we do?
We go back in this
implication graph,
learn a clause,
in this case not y1 or not y3.
This is what we learned, okay, I
missed the animation step here.
So yeah, so we learn a clause,
add it, and continue.
This gives also rise to the
complexity of this algorithm,
the next space
algorithm like CDCL.
Because in the worst case,
we have to add all clauses.
In particular, in the case that
all variables occur in all
clauses, we get
really big clauses,
right, really a lot of
clauses in the end.
All right, cool.
So we can actually go
already to the evaluation.
Now I wanna get back to the-
>> Can you garbage collect
clauses?
>> Pardon?
>> Can you garbage
collect clauses?
>> Like in start overs, like
heuristically delete some or?
Yeah, we can.
I mean, as long as you
eventually allow to learn many,
yes.
>> [INAUDIBLE] you can
trade restarts or?
>> These are things I
won't show here, but
yeah, my algorithm
does do restarts and
the implementation
does the restarts, and
also experiments with
[INAUDIBLE] clauses,
even though that [INAUDIBLE]
doesn't have so much.
Pretty much because the rate at
which it learns clauses is 100
times slower than
in start overs, and
so it never collects that many
clauses that's reading issue,
though that might change,
so it's not, yeah.
Okay, we're gonna take a look
at the benchmarks that we've
defined earlier,
writing functions,
function summaries,
and problem sketches.
Then we'll take a look at
the history of eval evaluation.
Unfortunately, I have
only the 2016 results,
not the updated results.
I'll talk a bit about that,
and then about certification.
Now, ranking functions.
So it will other things,
QF algorithms is a bit hairy,
but we'll walk through that.
We see solid lines and
dashed lines.
Dashed lines are those that
use pre-processing and
solid lines are those that
don't use pre-processing.
The reason why you don't see
many solid lines is that
without pre-processing,
these algorithms cannot solve
basically any of the benchmarks.
All right, so
this is pretty sad.
We see that one red line
which is depth QBF5,
because it kind of
uses in processing and
it could deactivate that and
then it would.
So it uses the pre-processed
techniques, just like y is
running and therefore sort of
at least solves some of them and
if you use the full
pre-processor,
it can solve
basically everything.
And this is why all these lines
are pretty much the same.
But as soon as
the pre-processor stops,
the algorithm still cannot
solve much in this benchmark.
It's a bit hard to see these.
I think that these algorithms
can solve all but two or
three of these benchmarks.
However, CADET, which is our
implementation of incremental
the algorithm I just presented,
can solve all of them, and
it can typically solve it a
factor of two to five faster, or
something like this.
It's typically in the order
of 20 milliseconds,
maybe sometimes up to 100 here.
I think the worst case was a
couple of seconds and these were
benchmarks that included 64 bit
encodings of small programs.
That's kind of reasonable.
It's already pretty nice.
Of course,
here the pre-processor,
because it's standardized or
pre-processor,
it could solve pretty
much everything.
It's maybe not the most
interesting benchmark yet.
Now this is
a different benchmark,
the function summaries, where
it looks a little bit different.
Again, dashed lines represent
the solvers with pre-processor,
the other lines without.
Again, without pre-processing,
the algorithms cannot
solve anything.
With pre-processing,
they sort of get somewhere but
the pre-processor was sort of
slowing things until that point,
or that one.
Now we have some other lines
straight through it and
I won't go too much
into details here.
What we see is that again, CADET
computation is like a factor of,
and this time like 10 to 20
times faster on the average
instances and
can solve everything here.
That's pretty cool.
Can even like really solve.
These were actually interesting.
Like the computation
of function summaries,
it's actually a nice
certification effort.
For the synthesis and
benchmarks, it couldn't
solve everything.
It doesn't quite
continue like that and
also the gap was really smaller.
I mean, sometimes for some time
bounds and others even better,
and then it turns out that
with a 600 second time,
we could solve pretty much.
I kind of cut off the graph
here, because there are a lot of
really boring instances and
then I think only the last,
like 20 or
40 were really interesting.
And we're going to see like
this, let's move forward,
get somewhere.
Now I want to add to your, this
comparison again really like
it's hard to compare these
algorithms because all
the items are not super clean
interpretations of just
one thing but they try to do
some tricks here and there.
Like us, also this we can do,
so for example in our CADET
implementation, I also
implemented that when it sees
that it can just enumerate
a certain thing and
it's reasonably small with some
arbitrarily chosen CADETs,
it will do that.
I mean it's only interest is to
solve the thing, it's not only
a clean implementation of
the incremented condition.
Even though that is the main
thing that happens and for
most of the instances,
it's sometimes also this is.
So, I just wanna to add
a word of warning here,
it's not 100% clean and neither
of the algorithms are clean
implementations of anything,
I would say.
It's a bit offensive.
Maybe I'm a bit too harsh here,
anyways.
So the tree of QBFEval 2016
looks like that which is
pretty cool.
CADET is pretty strong here.
This is a 2QBF track only.
However, for the 2017 benchmark,
I hadn't time to
generate this graph.
There, CADET only won
the second prize,
because there was another
solver that came into the race,
that has solved four
instances more, or something,
three more but the other solvers
are still kind of far off.
This new solver is basically
doing reconstructing a circuit
representation from the CNF and
tries to do CEGAR on top of
that and that apparently
solves all sorts of things.
I'm not exactly aware of
what this guy's doing but
we'll look into that.
So there's still some
competition going on, I would
say, between the two approaches,
yes, I don't wanna CEGAR is bad,
just it seems to be some
decent progress happening.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah, GhostQ, last year it was
still pretty off from the other
solvers, and it won competitions
in some earlier instances like
you see the yellow lines.
This one, but apparently he
implemented some user could
detection that is way better
than the earlier one and
it could solve more.
l don't know what
the exact advantage is,
exactly that he is mutually he
improves this thing, l know.
All right, all right,
I think we can see
that this new algorithm
actually helps us to solve more
instances like interesting
verification benchmarks.
It doesn't rely on
a enumerating inputs,
it's often really fast
like average instances or
easy instances, and it doesn't
require pre-processing.
CADET never used any kind
of pre-processing, which is
really important if you want to
create a proof over the formula.
And that gives rise to this
picture which is a bit show off,
maybe too much.
Year collected instances from
all these benchmarks and
Randy ran the only two solvers
that are able to certify.
It gives us that third one,
that's also due to me and
a colleague but that's pretty
much the same as that DepQBF and
it measured, for
the different instances,
the sizes of the certificates.
And not only can CADET solve way
more, also, the certificates
are just like many orders
of magnitude smaller.
That's not really surprising,
because there are certificates
that look like that.
This is probably an adder or
something, or a plus one,
I don't think so,
an increment maybe.
And these lower triangles
are intervals of variables,
these uppers
are essential variables,
or I think also the nodes
are essential variables.
And enumerating all
the assignments for
this thing is just, I mean,
just takes way too long.
And DepQBF couldn't use many
of these optimizations,
you have to deactivate the just
to be able to certify and
you cannot use
pre-processing right now.
There is some efforts to
re-enable pre-processing and
kind of carry through
these certificates, but
it's still a bit hairy,
it didn't really work for me.
And so it's not surprising that
DepQBF really, the number of
gates and this reshoots it, it
does a huge case of things and
array over everything is
really not effective.
CADET on the other
hand can basically
propagate these structures.
It didn't invent the structure.
It does this in the instance,
and just propagated it.
So it's fine.
It didn't do much work.
It just grabbed the definitions
that are in the problem,
all right.
So, I need to spooze out these.
You see there's some weird
things happening below here,
below there.
So it probably added some weird
clauses there, learn some new
clauses and then it returned
that thing Okay, now,
to summarize this first part,
we are pretty much at the end.
We have seen that this
algorithm, we've seen
this definition of propagation
of unique consequences and
unique skull functions.
The partial function,
how confident that this works,
roughly, and what's terminating,
as I mentioned,
it enumerates all the classes,
and we've see the evaluation.
What we've not seen is,
all the details like exactly
how it's implemented.
It's pretty close to SAT solver
when it's down implementing it.
It's really not that
much of a difference,
just that you need to have like
this extra SAT solver inside,
that kind of generates
conflicts and so on.
And there's other notions that
really help to speed things up,
like pure literals, restarts,
visitor heuristics, and so on.
And these are all implemented
in there, in the software.
Okay, I wanna,
last couple of minutes,
I wanna at least
add one new note.
One interesting note,
and this algorithm can,
I think one view on the
algorithm is that it can really
symbolically compute functions.
Scoring functions only,
only for GPBF right now.
And the question is whether we
could maybe extend it to compute
not only scoring functions,
but general functions.
The difference is that for
2QBF, scoring functions all
have the same domain, if
we might wanna induce functions
that have different domains.
You might wanna actually work
with a logic that can introduce
extentially quantified functions
that have different domains.
And then here we have sort
of QBF here that can use
the function
applications inside.
There is a logic called DQBF
that can pretty much do that,
but it's also similar to EBR
if you do some coding tricks.
So that'll be super interesting,
and
I think in particular for
verification purposes,
it will be amazing to have as
a symbolic algorithm with that.
We can treat these functions
in a symbolic way,
because we can represent
the whole memory state, or
the whole state of a system
by that, by function.
We can even represent the whole
execution symbolically, which
is [INAUDIBLE] there's a method
of adding addresses to bytes,
right, simple.
And we can represent data
structures, arrays, strings,
maps, and so on with functions.
So functions are the natural
way how to formulate problems,
how to think about it.
Also, we humans would never
enumerate the inputs of
a function, we'd kind of
think of them symbolically.
Also, our proof of place like
ranks, and ranking functions or
variance are naturally
expressed as functions.
Many of these things
I've been talking about
are currently addressed
by specialist algorithms.
For example, SMT solvers and
also in elsewhere, theories
like UF, Aries, and so on.
And, however, often,
they tend to represent these
functions as function tables.
By which I mean that they self
introduce one variable for every
possible input, at least for the
inputs they need to consider.
And so they kind of expanded
it into a more flat problem,
and solved it there.
And that is surprisingly
effective, I mean,
there has been a lot of work,
it's pretty good.
But I think we could maybe,
if you could maybe come up with
a symbolic algorithm, that at
least helps in the cases where
these other algorithms explode.
Now, the question for us is,
how could we possibly argue
symbolically about
these functions.
And I've not seen, I'm not
aware really of algorithms,
maybe in the first,
all our theorem proven well.
But also there, I'm not so sure,
I'm happy to hear your
opinions on that, yeah,
you seem to have a-
>> [INAUDIBLE].
>> Yeah, I try to, but so
far, he hasn't convinced me.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
I'll try to get more out of him.
Anyway, let me present where
I think this could go, and
for that,
I've been investigating
how we can possibly reason
about these functions.
And there's one major problem,
and that is that resolution
doesn't seem to work, or it
doesn't seem to cut it for DQBF.
So CDCL, so a solver for
DQBF is not just possible
because CDCL just does strictly
resolution in the end.
Now, for SAT and GBF,
resolution just cancels value,
you can solve SAT and
GBF by resolution,
by just billing all resolvents,
in principle.
And if you derive
the empty clause or
the clause at confidence
intervals, you're done.
For DQEF, the existing example,
due to it's just that this
is not possible with DQEF.
Now presume we have this logic
that allows these function
applications in clauses, just
treat them as atoms for now.
And in the appendix is this
formula, which is this one
function that has bits to bits,
single bits to single bits.
And then the formula just says,
whenever x1 and
x2 are true, than f of x1
should be the same as f of x2.
I mean,
the one direction is easy to do,
fine, but the other direction
actually doesn't seem to be.
So it's like, it is clear that
such a function cannot exist,
there's just too many
assignments for which these are,
three assignments of x1 and
x2 where they are not the same.
But f of x1 and
x2 cannot be consistently
defined to satisfy the equality.
And you can try it
out in your head,
it's really a small
combinational problem.
And it turns out that,
even if you
try to build more resolvents for
this sea of classes,
all the resolvents are either
trivially true, or
they're already contained
in this set of classes.
So you cannot derive a new
class, but the formula is false,
so resolution
doesn't cut it here.
Now, and
all the complete [INAUDIBLE] so
far essentially also in the end,
and
to resolve it only by expanding
the function tables, yeah?
>> [INAUDIBLE] first
class [INAUDIBLE].
>> You could try to insert like
concrete values, yeah, but
then you end up
enumerating values, yeah.
>> No, [INAUDIBLE]
why do you claim that
the solution cannot
derive a new clause?
>> You literally cannot
derive a new clause
through resolution in this.
I mean, you just take,
say the first two-
>> [INAUDIBLE] the right format,
so you have the universal
quantifiers in each clause,
right, so
[INAUDIBLE] conjunction.
>> But they are [INAUDIBLE]
quantifiers that are there
globally, right?
I know that in, for
first theorem [INAUDIBLE] state,
you kind of try to keep
quantification locally.
And you try to unify clauses and
so on, you can do that,
that algorithm works.
And however,
in practical applications,
it seems that these solvers are
absolutely not even competitive
with enumerating things.
In the QBF competitions,
we had a submission from
an APR solver that
converted QBF to APR, and
couldn't solve
basically anything.
>> [INAUDIBLE] too
many algorithms.
>> Right, because the encoders
that you're interested in have
10,000, 50,000 losses.
This is not really
the realm of these.
>> So [CROSSTALK]
>> I agree,
I don't wanna dismiss
their work, but
I think your claims
are not correct.
This resolution network this is
literally a proof in their work,
and I checked it myself to
really go through this thing.
You can take any two classes,
build the resolvent, and
it's either triply true, meaning
it contains opposing literals,
or it is already
contained in that thing.
I mean, the first two ones, for
example, if you resolve them
with a pivot, f of x1 is triply
true because then you have f of
x2 and Okay, I'm not going to-
>> I mean,
the [INAUDIBLE] solver, but
not through resolution.
>> Yeah, so you're saying you
can't solve this problem just
treating f(x1) and
f(x2) as atoms.
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> As propositional atoms,
but it's not [INAUDIBLE].
>> If you want to replace them,
and instantiate them,
yes, you can.
Then you can solve it, but
then you are in the realm
of the enumerating values.
>> [CROSSTALK]
>> I'll be happy to-
>> I'll show you.
>> Cool, I will be very
interested in that,
actually, yes.
So we kind of then,
from that point on,
took a different route than
instantiation, definitely.
We use a simple proof system for
DQBF that [INAUDIBLE] and
now we're kind of short on time,
so I'm gonna make this fast.
For that,
to talk about this briefly,
we have to introduce
the actual notation of
DQBF which doesn't usually
come with functions.
Typically, it's formulated in
terms of quantifiers that there
exists a function f
that has these inputs.
Where these are all these
universal variables, and then we
can use that f, which actually
is sort of the function of f2,
these elements
inside that formula.
Now, this is a sort of just
normal function where every
function just has
one set of inputs.
And actually it turns out, we
reproved [INAUDIBLE] we couldn't
just revive that with
a linear blow-up.
So we couldn't rewrite this
quantification of a function
with a linear blow-up into that
quantifier representation,
pretty easy.
So we now just have formulas
like that, we say okay,
we have some symbol y1,
that depends on the inputs x1.
We have some symbol x2
that depends on x2, and
let's just zoom into one clause,
x1, x2.
The question that is really
important to ask here, or
that really helped me
to understand this is,
who's responsible for
satisfying that clause?
If we're in SAT, that is,
if x1 and x2 are empty, so
they're both
propositional variables,
one of them statically
satisfies a clause.
It has to for any solution here,
otherwise it would be violated.
For QBF, we know that either x1
includes x2, or x2 includes x1.
Probably because x2 occurs
behind x1 in the quantifier
prefix, it includes maybe
more universal variables, and
not at the other end.
And then we can say, whenever
we cross multiply by y1,
y2 has to satisfy it.
And it can know because it
knows more universal variables.
Anyways, now we can, in DQBF,
we don't have that property.
This could be incomparable,
x1 and x2 could be just like,
neither one includes [INAUDIBLE]
nor the other way around.
Okay, in this case, and the
basic insight was that y1 and y2
would have to coordinate based
on their shared information.
So based only on the values
that occur both in x1 and x2,
it has to be clear which
side satisfies the clause.
And this gives rise
to our proof rule,
which essentially says given a
clause with two separate parts.
Where the one part cannot depend
on the dependencies of the other
part, and
the other way around, so
they're incomparable
dependencies.
And then we can introduce
a fresh variable, t,
that just depends on the section
of the two dependencies.
And this variable t controls
which side of the clause has to
satisfy the original clause.
So we introduce a new function
that resolves this thing.
We call these clauses
information forks,
sort of,
there's a similar term in
[INAUDIBLE] synthesis of
distributive systems,
because it's sort of
the same effect here.
Then we just need the two
standard rules for
proving QBF formulas, resolution
and universal reduction.
Universal reduction just says,
if we have a class full
of universal, we can drop them
all, create the anti-clause.
Now, in the example
that comes with this,
this is just the previous
example with our functions.
Just that now the functions
are called, I mean, with this
equality of the functions,
if and only if x1 and x2 holds.
Just that now the f1 and f2
are unfortunately called y1, y2.
So what we just do is we split
all the clauses, because they
all have this property
that they have y1 and y2.
And we introduce these
variables t1 to t6, and
choose positively here and
negatively here.
They all have anti-dependencies
because the intersection of set
of x1 and x2 are empty.
And then we just
apply resolution,
we get a formula only
over the variables t.
We apply more resolution in our
anti-clause, and we are done,
we have proven it to be false.
So this works,
and we have a proof that it
makes resolution complete.
I mean, these three rules follow
a complete process for DQBF and
we can solve in a very
symbolic way, I would say.
Formulas that re-quantify our
functions, it's pretty cool.
So far,
no implementation exists, so
that's really hard to say
whether it's going somewhere.
By hand, we were able to solve
some formulas by that that
are sort of interesting,
but of course, that is so
far just an exercise in 3D.
I don't wanna claim I know how
to create an efficient solver
around that.
But there is a sort of
connection to [INAUDIBLE] that I
believe is there and
I'm still working on that.
Anyways, okay, now, okay,
I don't want to go into the last
part because now
time is running out.
It's, anyways,
a very interesting thing,
the quantitive synthesis part,
we can approximate synthesis
create with SAT solvers.
It's a really cool thing,
but I'll leave that out,
and we're going to
jump to the end.
Okay, I have presented
the incremental determinization
algorithm for 2QBF.
I sort of sketched out how
this could be maybe lifted to
quantifying over general
functions, Boolean functions,
of course.
And there's more work in this
area that I would also be happy
to talk about if
you're interested.
I'm here all day, and
happy to take questions and
discuss later.
>> Can you just say what
qualities this is solving?
>> Okay.
>> What's the problem?
>> The very short summary is,
>> Okay, we solved that problem.
You're given some function from
exponential space of natural
numbers to non-exponential
space of natural numbers.
And where the function can be
sharply hard to compute for
a single input, we have
exponentially many inputs,
each input is sharply hard.
And we have no
convexity assumption,
no assumption at all about this
function, not even that it has
an informative derivative or
anything.
And [INAUDIBLE] you can
find an input that is
probably close to the maximum.
And that with only pulling
normally many class SAT solvers,
that's the shorter.
>> [INAUDIBLE].
>> It's through model counting,
and
there's a very neat trick how we
can extend that to actually turn
it into an optimization
algorithm.
Yeah.
>> So I think let's thank
Marcus for his presentation.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Thanks.